Greetings from Northern California. Oh, hello Northern California. Our blood cancers such as chronic lymphoma
estrogen driven um no so the blood cancers are not going to be estrogen driven
cancer so the estrogen driven cancers are going to be breast cancer
uterine cancer ovarian cancer things like that that are going to be estrogen driven that's the
cancers that are be tested for ERPR or HER2 positive or negative so you won't have to worry about
that. I mean so should somebody not worry about their estrogen? I wouldn't say that. You still
should not ignore the Zenoestrogens because they cause other damages too so does everybody need to
do a hormone test um no but there is benefits to doing a Dutch test especially for a female
because we're so exposed to somebody's Zenoestrogens and understand the definition Zenoestrogens
are the estrogens that you get from your from the environment in estrogen disruptors that affect
your hormone balance from the environment so um whether you have cancer or not or whether you have
an estrogen or progesterone or HER2 positive or negative cancer um there can be great benefit to
looking at your estrogen progesterone, energy and levels and a good way to do that is through what's
called a Dutch test it's a dry yeary test um easy to get you can order it on our site and um you do it
at home and set it into the lab and it gives you a lot of data for the money to really see what's
going on and I you know it's it is interesting because you'll see people that are like might be off the
board with um uh search and hormones and it can then when you do when you start to read up on it it
can lead to a lot of other symptoms you're having and understand if person has okay let's say I have
lymphoma well it has nothing to do with estrogen but it can lead to a lot of other cold morbidities
and ability for my immune system to function and to be able to fight off other diseases and